ich begrüße ganz witzig
eine sitzung uns ist in mir über das
thema nicht auf diesem schönen wetter
dass dies schon fast komisch bei so
einem wetter ein seminaren zu bieten und
alle terrorismus ich habe ihnen gesagt
ich halte organismus führen
interessanteste form des unmoralischen
und zwar deswegen weil hier die moral
selbst ins spiel kommt hier wird die
moral selbst moralisch gewissermaßen man
denkt ja eigentlich wie kathedrale um
normale sterne waren es dann auf der
sicheren seite oder man ist auf der
sicheren seite wenn man auf die moral
sagte aber er gibt zwei anwendungen erst
mal kann man nur sagen jeder und jeder
versteht etwas anderes unter moral oder
wieder und wieder sieht die moral
waren die boote kann das bloß der eine
lebt sie strenge aus die anträge
schwächer und dann hängt natürlich immer
damals zu sagen wie man sich selbst zu
moral verhält und ich möchte jetzt wie
machen möchte ich ihr zu beginn geben
[Musik]
watson auf einmal ein rückblick geben
auf die letzte sitzung die fragen
zielten die preissetzung welche formlose
kubanischen veranschaulicht genau wohin
sollte er gar nicht so viel morgen ist
wir müssen sie ja eigentlich ein rudel
verwiesen
sichtbar sein die sich denn das ist ja
dieser pott wissen sie auch wer diesen
begriff eingeführt hatte konrad lorenz
genau und konrad lorenz war ein
verhaltensforscher und deswegen müssen
wir das ganze ein bisschen
problematisieren und kann ich einfach
kategorien aus dem tierreich auf
menschen übertragen wir sind auch die
ursache sind
wir sind neben besonderen jetzt werden
die ganzen tierschützerin und
tierschützer sagen nein wir sind ganz
normale tiere und wenn wir es als
besonderes gehört vertreten wie eines
bbc es muss das ist übrigens eine ganz
interessante form das ungarische
speziesismus bedeutet werde
in anlehnung an erasmus als von peter
singer gedrängt worden dass man sich
etwas besseres hält noch immer an einer
bestimmten natürlichen art zugelegt also
zum beispiel art menschen und das also
menschen etwas besseres sein nur weil
sie menschen sind wände zur art mensch
gewinnen und irgendwelche reichlich
andere tiere menschenaffen die natürlich
weitere angehört
und das ist nicht immer
dass rassismus entwickelt worden und da
ist was dran also
kubas zugehörigkeit noch gar nichts
wussten aber ich denke schon dass danone
jetzt als pcs ist sein zu wollen dass
die menschen die unsere besondere tiere
sind schon des kann ganz verschiedenen
dingen fest machen was nicht heißen soll
dass auch tiere den schutz gewesen zog
das schließt es ja nicht aus
menschen sind ganz besondere tiere dann
heißt das nicht dass wird die schläge
nicht kommentieren machen dürfen was wir
wollen oder was folgt daraus
keineswegs und kann ob sein andere tiere
verfügen auch über ganz besondere
eigenschaften zum beispiel delfine
besitzen eigenschaften sie sind auch ein
bisschen fast 1 million personen
erscheinen lassen
durch ihr sozialverhalten da muss man
dann immer ganz im einzelfall genau
hinschauen was war nochmal das
problematische von morgen wenn man noch
mal hier kurz zusammenfassen
damit blicken auf täterinnen oder täter
und opfer was ist das problematisch
angehen dass man sie mit einem kurzen
satz sagen sollten
das haben wir vielleicht ganz kurz zu
minute
[Musik]
das paket das alte wasser eigenschaft
als professor des täters kann man über
dem täter mit der täterin handelt es
sich um einen einzeltäter
das kommt bei der ehrung diskriminierung
sprechen terminierung des bieres
die ersten arbeiten treten
[Musik]
genau und aus ganz österreich als
machete in sieben modulen was ist das
ja genau das wird bestimmt ist
bei diesen rufen
[Musik]
was machen wir
die themen
währenddessen nicht direkt gewählt neben
zu stark und werden sich das wollte der
backwaren nicht die wollen
die opfer können die bundesschuld wäre
das nicht so klar wie man die
gewöhnliche das mit direkt und indirekt
schmerzt
sie kann ihre schikanen physikalisch ist
es hängt natürlich auch dass die
patientin habe ich denke dass
interessierte befassen man macht das
leben dieser opfer schwer gemacht ihm
das leben schwer
das kann man nicht stigmatisieren waren
damit unmöglich machen und es ist auch
bisher verborgen
[Musik]
diese frage zu warum ist es bilde ich
mir das normalen dass sich gemobbt
werden das gehört ja zum operation dass
man das opfern und land haben lässt und
dann die nächste frage warum gerade ich
das mache ich denn dann schaut man sich
häufiger im spiel irgendwann hier in der
sonne
das was die denn die ganze zeit also
großes fragen ausgestanden ist ob er
vergebens sichern
das opfer mit dem opfer der sich auch
spieler nachdenken
[Musik]
ist sehr sehr reflektierte von der
gruppendynamik bundes ist sich die
eskalation angehen es ist recht bald
richtig ankommen ist stark
[Musik]
ja es zu gewalt das heißt ja auch
geschrieben dass es kann natürlich auch
unterschwellig passieren dann spricht
man auch von viele jetzt das heißt ja
also ich würde sagen auch um
manipulation und das ist im spiel
die psycho thema finde ich das verstehen
das ist so
die floskel zum leben irgendwie gar
nicht klar ist was damit gemeint ist
damit habe ich noch probleme mit
psychotischen aber mit mobbing und die
schikanen
[Musik]
jemanden das leben schwer
das kannst du sonst noch um welche
punkte die man eher zu
dann haben wir gesagt deren gestrichen
worden also die stadt also im smoking
bestellt
die schule natürlich und auch nicht auf
ein bestimmtes alter das ist auch
interessant
ich denke gemobbt wird überall befasst
war
in bestimmten geschlossen und systemen
und tendenziell und auch zu jedem alter
in jedem alter
ich glaube nicht dass es irgendwie hier
nur schmecken dürfte oder studenten
das ist im arbeitsleben genauso und es
kann wirklich jede altersstufe betreffen
denke ich das ist
ja gut immer
[Musik]
musterbriefe
also klare strukturen aber zumindest als
zwischenlösung hammer ag wie das
original am stärksten ausgeprägt ist
wenn es sich um eine soziale struktur
mit ganz stark ausgeprägten hier war
china sehr gerne möchte immer dem unten
eins drauf geben und nach oben buckeln
dass man eben dann nach oben befördert
wird und die von war unmöglich sich vom
leibe
so eine struktur scheint mobbing zu
begünstigen
und hier könnte man jetzt zum beispiel
eine kleine wohnung desto weniger als
eine gestalten
völlig
des mobils
statt
[Musik]
ließen jeweils
das leid das wurde ungewissheit des
opfers in das mobbing systematisch mit
einbezogen ich möchte hier nicht von der
herkunft des mobilen spielens werden
entsprechend wenig zu wissen ich würde
mich schon der ganze ort den strengen
aber es ist nicht mehr ganz so werben
wie andere sehe strategischen form des
protests strategie spielen
es gibt sogar besser gesagt eine
strategisch es gibt sofort drehbuch und
das rad das wirklich organisiert ist es
hat zum verfasste dramaturgie ears tag
des mobbings und bringen ihr steckt
heute machen wir den oft das leben
schwer
[Musik]
ich sehe hier kann man sehr interessant
uns ein sehr trauriges phänomen bis wir
müssen natürlich dazu sagt das sollte
mir werbung eines youtube nutzers oder
youtube nutzerin
das ist auch der fall sein
dass man sich fälschlicherweise als
opfer sieht bis 10 bin wo man es gar
nicht ist
das macht die sache noch schwer aber
dennoch bin ich der meinung wer den
eindruck hat gemobbt zu werden der muss
ganz genug werden die muss man diese
sache müssen auch die konnten aber es
kann auch sein dass man sich das wetter
als opfer stilisiert aber dennoch
sollten
ein bisschen der norm knochen läuten
wenn das jemand sagt dass er den
eindruck habe gesagt werden
das genau ist und es auch die
möglichkeit gibt es nicht
wenn es dem sonst nur auf messen sowie
speziell daran scheint mir das schon vor
zu besitzt aber einigkeit gestreckt
philosophische fragen anders enden
lassen dass ihre arbeitsrechtlich eine
juristische frage vielleicht auch mit
soziologischen und politischen wir
müssen hier mal aufpassen dass wir hier
den gewinn philosophischen gehalt aus
dessen formen herausziehen psychologie
mit wenn der urlaub aber nicht
ungewöhnlich und zeigt natürlich alles
in toilette sind haben sie noch die mit
ihren werken zu bekleben lassen
interessante fall ein täglicher
das nicht da das zugeschrieben haben die
wissen berichtet ein
hintergrund sind und sagen dass morgen
darauf gibt das ist definitiv in die
rechte des man sich kaum aus dem haus
gelebt und die fraktionen darauf der
führend ist es brauchen
uns ist einfach aus bösartigkeit markt
[Musik]
das ist wahrscheinlich
gutschreiben
aus möglich machen hier ist hinter hat
morgen bekommen sie sprechen diese
internationalität ist was ich jetzt
nicht hatten
garantin
zu geplanten springen
ich denke sie hat
[Musik]
dieses kann sein das ist irgendwie eine
gewisse richtung wickede gar nicht mag
es nicht
das sind diese unüberschaubar noch an
dynamik ist wieder mit soziologischen
sache natürlich aber wir sehen dass zb
auch bei anderen in ihrer analyse wird
totalitären herrschaft also das ist eine
politisch philosophische geschichte wie
warten andere große verbrechen den
stetigen als ist eigentlich ganz kleinen
dingen wie in den spielen
ich kann das ganze kann es keine
skalieren und wer mich dass er wechseln
diesen diese tiefe von 1 ganz klar aber
das ist überstanden
[Musik]
also man weiß gar nicht wo man landet
aber man stellt sich schon auch mal war
es nicht es hat schon gewisse momente
ok also soviel zu den menschen kommen zu
jetzt kommen wir zurück zur
diskriminierung ist sie wird es nochmal
rückblick das ist ein ganz interessanter
forscher italienischer kriminologin aus
dem späten neunzehnten jahrhundert der
heißt tänzerin und große ich habe mehr
wissen
jetzt unterschrieben weil ich klebe
besonders interessant könnte wenn es um
das thema diskriminierung und
stigmatisierung geht der hat ein buch
geschrieben
das heißt wir mit der wegen schlechter
ist eine mannschaft die einen schaffen
er hat hier gegen eine diskriminierung
dem trieben heutzutage fast lächerlich
wirkt das würde heute niemand mehr
machen aber ich habe mich deswegen ein
paar zitate von bringen dass man einfach
sieht wie sich jedoch die zeiten zurück
sensibler werden aber wie man dort immer
wieder anfällig ist für kurzschluss ich
würde sagen das klinikum hat auch was
einen fehler gestand in einem
vorgespräch zu tun als man geht von
zeichen aus
[Musik]
das diskriminiert gesellschaft
auszeichnen geschlossen aber auch enorme
tele erklärt hier ist zeit mit norbert
internet
[Musik]
das ist glaube ich eine vision
es ist eine form in der mitte zu haben
eine falsche interpretation
die messstation weil sich alles so
schnell wie diese zeigen die daten und
die zeit
zeichen sind
mehr
[Musik]
gar nicht gab es sind
das ist ein gutes zeichen
[Musik]
eine person wasser standen
dieser mensch schafft diese eigentlich
auf dieser achse und so weit ist
[Musik]
erschließt was diese zeit darstellt
dessen zeichnen
eine dahinter liegenden organischen
problematischen schlechten meistens
neben negativen
das ist also ein falsches das kann dazu
aufstellen müssen eben die musik
bezeichnen
selbst die man bestimmte eigenschaft
besonders hervorheben dass man als
solches daneben ein opfer entschädigt
die zu schlafen
zu lesen wer der bessere ist alles
natürlich dahinter eine bestimmte
zeichen die ganze person vergisst als
mann reduziert interesse zeige gewesen
durch diesen
sieht es aus wenn der bestehende
malischen regierung
thematische natur die dahinter stehen
das kann eben ganz schnell das hirn
einnehmen dazu die ganze welt zu
interpretieren wir sind immer sehr
schnell mit schlüssen
das ist auch notwendig um überleben zu
können das nicht erschließt
[Musik]
der 1
und wer heute hier und da gibt es neben
die geschichte verkannt habe wo geben
dann dieses kainsmal dann den kein ziels
keiner hat er den bruder schlagen in
dieser geschichte im buch genesis ist es
noch so dass die diskriminierung dar als
irgendetwas positives verschafft
das ist ein schutz hinzu
[Musik]
die zeugen
das thematisierung abgrenzung aus
kritzmow unterscheidung enorm und aus
die fliesen der künftigen die nicht mehr
nur wenn es möchte ich einmal erreicht
werden sicherlich wollte verstand aber
der hat man damals ganz diese motoren
das ist morgen stellte er sagt die erste
gruppe mit seinem betrachteten personen
ist die der mörder wege leiten und
italien handschriften ist durch das du
durch langes ausziehen der buchstaben
kenntlich das sind die herren vom fach
dieser schriftart die schwer für mich
das heißt die mehrere hunde und zugleich
eines der verleger
buchstaben oder urspringen wie viel ist
der querstrich am geschäfte oder
längeren eigenheiten der krebs mit
energischen menschen anderen werden die
grundstücke in haft und der buchstabe
spitze winkel allem aus dem namens mit
einer menge von strichen und apotheker
verschieben
das würden wir durch mit jedem anderen
unterscheiden kann durch dich dann
wieder der streitkräfte
das ist ein zeichen für eine energische
wesens
für wissenschaftlichen wären die kraft
nur geben wenn man das zu sehr haben
stiften kunde von g
es gibt es immer noch das resultat der
handschrift rückschlüsse auf den
charakter zu ziehen
[Musik]
das kann man natürlich dann immer für
ihn ein als er dachte er könne hier
wirklich ganz wissenschaft objektiv die
handschriften von verbrechern studieren
nada neben geschaut hat ähnlichkeiten
hat daraus generalisieren induktiv
geschlossen
respekt mehr an der brenz und die
anstiftung von schwind lernte fälschen
ist opera toren standen dem nicht weit
genug gute strukturen tragen
vergewaltigungen in einen sicheren
schluss daraus ziehen sie wären dennoch
aber scheint es mehr als auch das
schwert ähnlich aussehende buchstaben
die durch förmige schluss buchstaben die
übertriebene stärke des namens zur es
viele ähnlichkeiten der schreibt
die leute hätten das verbrechen und sagt
er trieb den mann wie eine
naturerscheinung die philosophen würden
sagen wie eine notwendig erscheint auf
gleich denen der geburt des todes der
geisteskrankheit
wenn wir jetzt noch 18 als er sagt es
gibt hier sorgen
und das ist aus einer bestimmten
geisteshaltung des 19 jahrhunderts
wechsels von 19 zum zwanzigsten
jahrhundert die man auch positivismus
positivismus heißt dann geht ihr auf und
zeigen
geschlossen das heißt dass jede menge
müssten
die wissenschaft methoden
quantifizierbar ist das einfach nach
hause nehmen tage tritt und davon
schließen und auch das ist jetzt
natürlich besonders extrem aber der
glaube
im prinzip hat das was mit dem islam zu
tun
aufgrund von anzeichen dahinter ein
wesen oder natur herausfinden zu können
so hat ist das jetzt
wie die von somalischen piraten
mobile sind die ganzen der polizei
sie ist ein symbol des rassismus
wie wirkt in dieser zeit von der gruppe
seal
was geht da auf sie
was empfehlen
genau so eine bahn unter einem namen
musste am ende aber dass noch niemand
herum
das geht ja genauso gehen ganz genau das
zu nehmen
ich habe hier das a shout auf mich dass
es etwas gebeten die reklamierte
autorität deshalb von einer gewissen ja
auch anmaßung unter umständen zu tun sie
jemanden antwort auf der moralischen
richtigen seite zu sein und es zeit für
die liebe ihrer seite
das nächste dass er oben zeigt an wie
man damit ermahnen
mit diesem zeigefingers gerne nochmal
einmal diesen zeugt von der jetzt als
inszeniertes oben zeigt
man kann sich natürlich mehr in der home
anzeige wenn wir aber das ist also etwas
anderes würde man nichts sagen einmal
der schnellen erhebt sein zeiten in
welchen situationen man bekommt ein
erhobener zeigefinger bevor man nur dann
ihr mann haben sie den zweiten mal
poliert oder wann wurde er ihnen
gegenüber lebens immer möglichst etwa
zur situation des oben zeigen findet
wann besonders in welchem alter werden
sie am meisten mit der hohen zeige für
einen konfrontiert gewesen sein
ja
[Musik]
genau als kinder bräuchten also gut
diese gebiete sind es bei der beste aber
als kind wurde es als in ganz klaren
autoritätsverhältnis wo sie es mit
autorität für sich vielleicht ein wunder
schon im kindergarten aber ich weiß
nicht hat in meinem umfeld oder im
professoren gegenüber plant in zeiten wo
man lebt ja muss noch nicht unterbinden
und strahlen aber wichtig geist zu tun
nämlich der handel ist aber immer wie
zum beispiel von streit situation wenn
sie im gleichaltrige oder erwachsenen
menschen streifen haben dann kann es
durchaus sein dass der eine oder die
andere auch mal selbst meine zeigefinger
erheben oder bösen übrigens das sind ja
alles ganze unreflektierte ab
die betrüger sicher was macht man gar
nicht mehr wo man sparen
diese konnte
wenn du das doch ein gast ist dann bald
stieß das ist nicht verboten sind dass
der der drohenden der dann so ein
bisschen absorption anklagenden ich
zeige jetzt auf mich zeigt sie auch
diesen stunden zu merken wenn sie den
zeigefinger auf sich gerichtet sehen
das genügt schon sich betroffen
auch nur gespart als ich dort zeigt sich
auch an lehrern wenn du hier noch einmal
deshalb aus betont wobei das ist
natürlich der seine führt noch nicht hin
zwar kann auch erschüttert
[Musik]
kennen sie die lehrer lämpel aus max und
moritz gibt es ein ganz berühmtes bild
damit der bus fuhr er so gezeigt dass
die belehrung
natürlich ist es nicht gerade zum
beispiel muss man macht das man im auge
zu haben
normal dass ich meine zeigefinger heben
was zu unterstreichen den sie vielleicht
nicht immer das beste weil man dadurch
eine seine autorität sie sehr
symbolisieren also müsste man es mal
didaktisch reflektieren ob das gut ist
die meines wissen unterstreicht die
bedeutung
aber vielleicht ist es nennt
aus
[Musik]
neben sich auch immer ein bisschen
riskant hinaus fragen die nicht wird es
auf das treffen und mich jeder der
ermahnung
aber diesen gegenüber mitteln des
progressiven wieder wenn jemand das ist
man das gegenteil
[Musik]
die kanten sind damit sehr zusammen mit
dem eingeschritten
[Musik]
auch hier bestens bewährt
sie fühlen sich aber nicht
[Musik]
sie ganz abgelehnt
ja genau wo wir sind ja eher niedrig
genau das finde ich noch passender das
ist dieses belehrt in dem segment wissen
vielleicht eine besondere form der in
der 3
[Musik]
derjenige der dem zeigefinger wird
gewisse wirkung erzielen
bei dem um gegenüber ich sage ich dass
es immer noch dass sein muss aber das
sind mögliche höhe der zeit
und die band ist
[Musik]
oder jemand so recht genießen fühlt sich
mama
[Musik]
jeder wird und die anderen ja genau
diesen streit müssen natürlich dinge
ansprechen die nicht wissen die nicht
aber der wagen ist natürlich auch immer
umweht und man kann man auch das ja
nicht wiederholen und zeigefinger zu tun
stichwort feedback konstruktives
feedback nicht kannten feedback
oder auch ich kann niemanden so die
stigmatisierung oder das ganze
das wäre zum beispiel so dass ich nicht
diesen erhobene zeigefinger chronisch
aber auch wirklich mein ziel ist es
natürlich wieder ein bisschen
psychologischen aber noch mehr
vielleicht findet man taktisch oder
pädagogischen frage aber sie wissen ja
die psychologie wohnt in didaktik und
pädagogik sind ja alle aus der
philosophie hervorgegangen sie hängen
damit alle zusammen und ich denke dass
man im organismus diese ganze punkte
vermeiden könnte indem man einfach eine
andere forderung der kritikwelle
realität ist wichtig feedback ist
wichtig korrektur ist wichtig aber es
kommt auf die formel wie man diese
kritik ein kleid
beide formen inhalte abgreifen und ich
denke dass es auch der moralischen
moralismus betrifft wobei damit so ein
bisschen komplizierter und bei
moralismus ganz besondere form von
autorität ist da kommen jetzt auf zu
sprechen also für zehn minuten und
zeigefinger
jetzt habe japan leitfaden
berührt welche form von rassismus lassen
sie unterscheiden wer da war es kann als
journalistisch was ist ursache für alles
wegen organismus und andere form des
umgangs studie terrorismus mehr zusammen
warum ist realismus moralisch dramatisch
also war es noch nie vier stunden im
lieferumfang von moralismus leid
zugefügt
das sind so die immer kälter von
perspektive gleichermaßen berücksichtigt
wie beantworten
jetzt gibt's ja sogar von hermann
möglich ans buch nicht gelesen bin heute
bei der recherche eines möglichen
symbolisch für das für das dem
organismus nämlich die hobby zeigefinger
bin ich hier auch in den politischen
journalismus dieses buch von hermann
leben gekommen
die besinnung über die mutter ich will
damit nur sagen weil es muss der
außenpolitische philosophischen
vielleicht in anderen kontexten
berücksichtigt werden aber jetzt nicht
mit dem politischen und man ist und was
sagt das ist ein breites und jetzt haben
wir ein aufsatz für die umgestellte und
konstruktive kindes cable wireless it
introduction of your consideration die
distanz und micah richards auf das
process excellence and more than some
part of me
[Musik]
eine normative aber auch der
zuschreibung und schreibt
also wie viel man sich noch immer mit
einem
vestischen argument kommentiert
[Musik]
und auch
juli ist im reisebus kam der vormittag
in georgia mbh mfs ist es an dem
moralisten übertreibt es deswegen ist es
ist es das sind ex beatle bei youtube
branche mit allergischen das filmteam
meningitis oder moral ist außer der
deckte kenntnis ist die hektik als ist
sagt ein moralist betreibt ist also
nicht nur angemessen
[Musik]
es verlangt von uns zu viel die neuen
wiesen gebracht
händigen ist raten sie mal welche
philosophie welche klassischen besuch
besonders unter dem verdacht des
mortimer dem mms also über beansprucht
das motorrad an dem es steht ihr haben
ihn schon genauso präsent und zwar des
innern und weiter ins kategorie schild
gut
wer so viel glaubt jeden kategorische
gebote ausbauen zu können und wer glaubt
dass wir in keinem einzigen fall keine
ausnahmen bilden
das haben wir nicht verhandeln will
seiner seite ist kann ein moralist
das ist nicht überall wo über den spruch
und auf dem handy
dass wir ihnen gar keinen fall dürfen
wir für die glaubte abstimmung wer von
ihm glaubt kann das tan listen
es gibt viele die glauben sie nicht
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
also man kann zum beispiel sagen ihm
anerkannt
nachrichten musste
unsere ende bekannt erhebt das sehr gut
von unseren machen aber dann könnte man
sagen dann geht es gegen das wahlrecht
ist aber eindeutig italien verlangen
kannst du uns gerade china könnte aus
der theorie schon mal diskus folgen
eine andere frage damit zusammen dass
hatte ich glaube darauf geworfen
wer oder was schon oder zu durch die
leitfragen ja wer oder was kanton wallis
tisch sein
mir ging es immer beispiele
normalerweise so etwas wie leere lebte
die wärmegewinnung sehr gut erinnern sie
sich noch an der zählung lehrer lämpel
der spielt orgel und er braucht seine
pfeife und was machen max moritz
was tun sie den fall für einen dieb
lange anhalten
das erhalten was muss man denn der
explodiert und es ganz schön gesteht
hobby zum beruf gefährden ganze gesehen
jetzt kann ich aber dass der spieler
vielleicht als belehrung internet also
ich glaube auch gewesen
jedenfalls näher also also zum beispiel
personen kein moralist tisch aufdrängen
aber auch eine theorie kannibalistische
oder eine ideologie kann wobei das dich
zu machen oder kann auf realismus
passiert mir nicht sicher ob man der
meteorologie wirklich alles machen kann
aber ich glaube schon ich glaube zum
beispiel auch dass terroristen das würde
um 72 cent und frage die wir aufgerufen
haben und wie firmen geben terrorismus
mit journalisten zusammen hieß es die
vierte frage glaube auch dass ideologien
gewisse subjektivität und gewisse
überheblichkeit involvieren tönen die
man wolle die schnelligkeit theorien
glauben
sonntags es tut mir entsetzlich
aufmerksam als beck access controller
passiv moritz dunkel 12
so laufen kann er ist konnte menschen
auch kritisch zu wort wenn es um relativ
größten feind ist pietätlos
der deutsche trainer otto berlin das
teilweise kannst du das linzer komplett
liebt us-tv ende des prozesses ist
wahlweise behält die wiesn zu halloween
oberleitung und justin und auch ihr geld
weiter und fragt sie die mobile systeme
unter dem ließen die bedrohlich sein
die taktung moral sagt doch kann da auch
das umland
[Musik]
ja
ja erst mal kann man sich fragen was zu
behaupten war
jeder hat der romanze moral weit fasst
können dass gewisse grundsätze sind
normative grundsätzlich regeln gelten
sollten walter kannte ich sagen jeder
hat der andere war das wäre so weiter
kann man sagen also beteiligt war
eingeteilt eine normativ einschätzung
was konfrontiert du mich der mut
bewiesen
es schreibt hier einen nutzer auf
youtube in bezug auf mobile ismus haben
wir sonst wäre das andere extrem
woratschek gleich könig können
skeptizismus was wäre dann die
bezeichnung verdient die mission mit
dazwischen also bis moralismus zu großen
kurssteigerungen bis hatten wir hier in
der tat
[Musik]
hier
zu sehen ist ein sehr gutes
stinkt schon also müssen als bisher
heißt ja unmoralisch ist es ja nicht das
gegenteil sondern wird es seien also
praktisch gleise von agrarischen bereich
gültigkeit hätte wahnsinnig gerne
schnell gleichgültigkeit und moralischen
ignoranz also der eine die einen link so
leicht der antrieb tisch werden weil
damit glaubt auch nicht das ganze wesen
des journalismus erfasst
ich glaube nicht dass journalismus damit
das moralisch ist dass man es die moral
zu bringen falls sich glaube ich dass
das das problem ist nur dass - und ich
glaube das ist die idee des populismus
der oder die der moralischen realistisch
ist und das ist glaube ich jetzt noch
nicht wir diesen text kommt der bisschen
weiter unterhalten
amsel idee woran liegt das problem des
moralisten
ich glaube es liegt nicht darin dass im
rost oder sie belegten machen werden sie
jemandem journalismus kümmern
überlegen sie sich doch mal eine
konkrete situation sie bringt hier zwei
auf zeit der ausblick für das im oktober
auf mustern extreme rebound system von
camping robusten im extrem der verbrauch
spox weil eine in rieste ist meister von
characters with die das und welche
hessen ag ist weiter kritisch
zweites beispiel relief interessenten
jared etwas ist der konstanzer jusos
wird auf der exit not limited to the
great eight letters of the child und gw
bis 50 prozent dieser gries beliebigen
mit chisora der villa bosch super lotto
gewinnen
titel biss zinssatz ist es normal dass
noch einmal das zu retten mit der auf
der castor die konstanz es gibt die
arminia zehn prozent ihres jährlichen
einkommens an eine hilfsorganisation
ihre schwester dass du machst jetzt
nicht hier mit dem zeitfahren das ist
nicht genug
du musst mindestens 50 prozent
das zehn prozent das ist der beginn
stellt die besten zehn prozent kommst du
hier so viel schon davon
du willst doch ein gutes gewissen machen
du musst darunter wirklich in heiden
wenn du wirklich etwas gutes tun will
ist mit einem gerät du willst ja noch
frei könnte mein zweiter studientag der
konstanz wenn du wirklich dass gutes tun
will dann geht dann muss die npd muss
das spiel als 50 prozent ist die
konstanz angereist
weil gut
eigentlich gehört es ja auch
die wehr wieder doch auch die man das
ganze auch sozusagen
das ist ein guter punkt wir müssen noch
mehr auf denjenigen oder diejenige 8
liter diesen vorwurf macht es gibt auch
zum problem der scheinheiligkeit scheine
nicht dass ich sage das ist jener der
wasser gebe ich aber weiterhin dringend
oder jemanden der es ag 50 prozent aber
nächsten griff oder wenden
ich glaube nicht dass das genau auf den
fall des kommunismus zu tun habe ich das
kaum glauben dass der mond ist es
schaden erscheint damit wir wollen aber
dass die scheinheiligkeit anders
reduziert also ich glaube meine beste
constanze gewirbelt 15 prozent geben
wenn es nicht ihrer schwester helfen
würde wenn sie nicht 50 prozent geben
oder wenn sie dieselbe situation wie
aber ich glaube es kann durchaus 50
prozent geben oder würden sie nicht
sagen
sie wäre doch auch noch immer lästig
wenn sie dann 60 prozent geben wenn sie
nur wenn sie in ihrer schwester
vorwerfen würde 19 prozent zu geben
selbst der von 5 prozent geben würde
dann würde ich sie fast gar nicht mehr
als moralist bezeichnet und als feuchter
denn da erscheinen müssen
ich glaube damit wir sie überlässt sie
bezeichnen können muss sie will künftig
prozent geben schaut meist
ich gebe es sogar 60 du kannst auch noch
50 g aber ich gebe es also ich glaube
dass die verhöre mit enthalten die auch
tatsächlich moralische fundiertes
tatsächlich macht aber noch mehr an
gesprächen wird wegen des silber
schweigen ist gold
das geht sowieso wie richtung ich weiß
was genau zu erfahren
man sollte über seine guten tagen nicht
so viel werden aber auch das ist
natürlich wieder ein bisschen
realistischer aber dass man sagen je
mehr wirklich gutes tut sollte es auch
nicht
konstanz sind indirekt sich erheben
indem sie der anderen vor damit will sie
den rückschlüsse haben
schaut also in dem man sich selbst
erheben über antreten jemanden anderen
flächen also nichts zu sagen wenn nicht
direkt
ich gebe selbst wenn es zu wenige
patienten und am entscheidenden
qualifiziert zu sein
dass sich überhebt dass sie damit
indirekt sagen ich mache oder ob ich
würde es wohl ich bin normal chance sagt
es aber nicht direkt zu sehen
[Musik]
vergleicht man sich zum unterlegen ich
glaube dass ist was nach kuba hebelten
in besten bin moralischen ist als das
der moral ist nicht die mobilität mir
selbst betreibt was er eigentlich tun
sollte mit dem programm sollte
formalitäten zu stellen sondern er hat
nur ein interesse daran dass den anderen
wissen zu lassen dass der moralisch ist
und das wird den anderen wissen lassen
indem man dem anderen geschwächtes
gefühl verändert als er wird durch die
den einsatz durch die kommunikation des
moralisch was erfüllen ist wird er
nämlich wir die modalitäten wenden wir
sie einsetzen wie wir das im 21
ich glaube dass der punkt und sie wäre
dann moralisch die konstanz wenn ich
eine ballistische wunderbar wenn sie zb
alter form finden ich glaube es würde
reichen wenn sie das anders
wenn jetzt sagen würde 18 prozent finde
ich schon und ist besser als nichts aber
du kannst du darüber legen
sinn ergeben wird nur das was du
überlegst und nicht mehr überlegt
vielleicht wenn man das so sagt mit
einer frage könntest du mich vorstellen
noch ein bisschen mehr zu geben werden
würde
ich glaube diesen ton das geht es ja
auch letztendlich wird im rat also was
wir mit der sprache tun
allein durch sind etwas herunter
gestimmten beschreibenden tun können wir
der konstanz sind die novalis muss
nehmen diesen ballistische weise nehmen
[Musik]
hast du nicht nur überlebt sondern
glaube damit wäre sie gar keine wahl ist
in mehr wenn sie dessen mo-so fragen hat
oder wenn sie sagen weil ich finde es
schön wenn du noch ein bisschen mehr
geben aber ist nur meine meinung dazu
also ein bisschen bescheid
also - in der art der kommunikation
dieses organische dass der rauch des
sein können einfach nicht mehr diese
absolut ist zurzeit untergang
als kurz gesagt ich glaube aber es muss
des problems besteht nicht
in der übertriebenen oder moralischen
einstellung
sonst besteht in der kommunikation
diese moralischen einstellungen in der
die präzisen überheben behandeln
die frage ist natürlich die ist super
das hat so wichtig dass man mal ganz
extrem geht aber nicht die banken
dadurch und schlechtes gewissen macht
[Musik]
da ist aber denkt doch mal eine
verstimmte lebensformen muss was noch
geht
denken sie mal an menschen die ein
extrem war nichts leben leben extrem
warmer tag angeboten orientiertes leben
die aber dennoch für die moralisten sind
müssten sie man bayern hier in bayern
genau kloster mönche und nonnen zu
meistern
das ist eine meiner hat gewesen wenn
innerhalb und kloster besichtigen dass
die mönche total selbst genügt ich habe
nie den eindruck gehabt da hat jemand
den zeigefinger
das mag es nicht geben aber so meine
erfahrung ist im kloster ist kein ort
übergeben und zur tiefe münchen und die
respektierung des weißen turnschuhen
das sind
als wenn der tourist kommt ist das dann
lässig über in der jesus sagt nach du
willst ein bisschen sinn angebot an
oberflächen leben kommen kann es
weitergehen
ich glaube nicht dass das nicht
das hatte die nonne würde das schon
reflektieren ich glaube da haben wir
eine form von moral behörden glauben wir
erheben nicht diese tendenz ist muss er
weiß wie diese haben diese fröhlichkeit
ist beschreibung hyde ist daraus nicht
als ich dachte schon ich hatte mich noch
nie von münchen oder solchen leuten im
wallis tisch brand geführt aber es mag
sich auch gegen die fans ja gut ein
verstehen
es ist
[Musik]
ich dachte jetzt da wo wir euch daher
kommunizieren befolgt geboten
noch strenger dass es sicherlich eine
möglichkeit ich dachte er nach außen hin
daraus zog dass dieses abgeschottet auch
natürlich einzeln oder in münchen heißt
nur dass da nicht so sehr der
journalismus ausgedrückt in einer presse
agentur in der bescheidenheit scheint
der möglichen wesen gibt ein bisschen
die familien zu werden dieser ort ist
aber dass herr großmann
das jedenfalls glauben dass das problem
des terrorismus
das sind letztendlich vielleicht auch da
enttäuscht dass unsere themen wie sehen
sie das interpretations anbieten
also meine these konnte sagt wären
überdies das ist eine form der
selbsttäuschung dass man die mobilität
des endlichen es braucht um sich selbst
zu lieben und das wäre eigentlich auch
ein missbrauch der mobilität nehme ich
mir für die 21 dahin dass einem
letztendlich eignen sich selbst in die
mobilität mit vorgestellten und man
glaubt vielleicht das tun aber man kann
zur passion einsteigen und dann sich
selbst täuschen und vergessen uns da
gehen
sie stehen und das ist eine mischung aus
spüren zu lassen dass man selbst auf der
rechten seite steht
vielleicht auch weil man sich gar nicht
dass sie dir nochmal auf die rechte
seite steht und dadurch eigentlich noch
mehr sparen muss
ich glaube dass das dazu der welt
problem des journalismus ist und nicht
so sehr das übersteigerte form und auch
nicht die chance zu glauben dass dadurch
noch dort er spüre und genießen zu
müssen indem man den anderen wissen
lässt dass er es nicht ist sich selbst
auf der richtigen seite immer wieder
fühlen und spüren müssen erkennen müssen
das heißt dass ich kann nicht ganz
sicher man jetzt die richtigen seite zu
stehen
ich glaube dass es hier platzieren gibt
themen die den terrorismus ist soll
diese neben diskutieren schreibt in
einer urwahl ist in seinen augen war
child geht es vor allen dingen die
motivation der handhaltung behindert die
problematische stadt erzählen ja nur der
moralischen überleben kann
ich glaube dass das wichtig ist also
ließen die hand zum handlungs motiv mit
dem normal und ich das gute leben wie
kanzler habe achtung vor dem gesetz
dann wäre die habe ich jetzt endlich
sich selbst als sich selbst als etwas
was besonders das alter spielt die
individualität
dahinter kommen kann es ja und natürlich
welche den tod sind hier bitte doch ganz
glaube ich hab's mit dem superb die
sache super werde überheblichkeit
ich glaube dass das eine gute und immer
neue kant hat das auch den reigen
dunkeln genannt drittens weil ich ganz
genau erreichen können häufig an bei
kant etwas wo man glaubt man könne sich
ausnahmen gestatten von der strikt dem
oral ist nicht dasselbe habe ich glaube
auch global des muskels ein bisschen die
richtung ist noch ein bisschen komplexer
wenn man sie gar keine ausnahmen
gestattet sondern gestaltet in allen
deutschen geraten
[Musik]
ja das ist
ich glaube das ist dass die gefahr diese
totale immunisierung auch ich glaube zum
beispiel eine journalistin
[Musik]
ich habe darin radikalisieren noch
abschottung gegenüber von blähungen oder
berechtigte kritik von außen noch hier
[Musik]
zurück
bis 9
auf geht's los steigerte vor ort war
schon integrität moralischen ansprüchen
an sich selbst
die heilige vielleicht ein wenig
abgenommen
das ist noch nicht im organismus es war
ein problematischer als zu viel ist dass
er dessen ansicht nach ist es das zu
viel
aber ich glaube nicht dass aus dem
zuviel des moralischen anspruchs der
moral ist er weg snobismus ist nicht ein
zuviel an spaß sondern ist dass der
gehweg und diese zu viel
alles muss nämlich sich selbst zu heben
und sich dann aber total zu glauben ich
bin auf der rechten seite aber dass
jetzt endlich nun deswegen zu tun weil
man sich selbst etablieren möchte und
vielleicht auch gegen die behandlung als
etwas besseres
however ist der september ist sehr groß
wissen sie wenn es möglich ist dass dort
neue liste martin raiser hat heißt der
weltbestenliste
das geht so ein bisschen die heiligen
und auch wenn ich dieses leben will und
der esel hat der opa selbstgenügsamen
die hat einfach mehr hat zumindest wird
so beschrieben
ich kann ihren kopf reinschauen ich habe
mal im seminar war das gute gegeben
dann mache ich eben jetzt rechts und
links der stelle
habt ihr dieses gedankenspiel was wäre
wenn man jetzt tagebüchern von mutter
teresa finden indem sie im geschrieben
ihre gründe für ihr
und wenn sie darin also stehen würde
dass das notarin zu geben sie dann 100
der reeser nochmals eine gute
unterhaltung person an sich hätte es um
eine problem also kann ihnen versichern
ich glaube dass wirklich im radsport ist
auch etwas selbst aber es ist auch sehr
bescheiden und immer lässt trägt nicht
bescheiden noch nicht ganz im gegenteil
der tritt sehr exponiert sind natürlich
klar aber es gibt solche tendenzen dass
dann besonders exponierte personen auch
belehren zu bringen ich glaube da ist
ein bisschen gefährlich also dass nach
dem konzert im normzyklus den wandel zum
terrorismus machen wenn wir aber nochmal
genauer
aber ich möchte jetzt schluss da noch so
ein bisschen darauf eingehen kann diese
idee wie jetzt terrorismus mit nordisk
zusammenhängen könnte
im endeffekt gesehen ist es doch nichts
anderes als der versuch mit waffengewalt
seine eigene moralismus sollte auch
weiter ausblick umzumünzen aus
durchzusetzen
genau also ich glaube investments
könnte meniskus ist terrorismus ist eine
steigerungsform
und zwar als hier nicht mit dem opfer
stillschweigen leid zugefügt gewissen
eingeschritten sind dass der verlust
nicht weitergehen dass der aus demselben
und tiefen wie mir scheint wie ein
normales muss jetzt aber noch den opfern
nicht indirekt oder passiv dieses leid
zufügen sind ganz aktiv in der bestraft
also seid hier nicht gratis software ist
einfach sinn dass es wieder ist
diskriminierung sowie amt bewirbt solche
unterscheidung zwischen 4 auf der
rechten seite die ihr auf der falschen
seite
deswegen müsste ja auch noch bestraft
werden wir maßen uns an nicht maß an wir
sind gerecht wir sind gerecht für die
darin diese leute zu bestrafen
und jetzt ist halt das interessante dass
die gründe für die bestrafung ziemlich
natürlich erscheinen kann übrigens
einmal elfter september
was natürlich mittlerweile aber
überlegen was geht wohl in den köpfen
dieser terroristen vor sich dass gerade
das world trade center angriff war
was würde mit deren strategie die wir
haben sind diesen tat gewicht hätten sie
sind recht hatte das wird sie sagen das
war so die argumentation
als mobiles müssen
[Musik]
deswegen des wegen des windes und
deswegen das volk ist links man was wird
das einzeltier ist es helfen septembers
gesagt haben wenn sie in frage
ja
[Musik]
ja genau und damit sind sich diese
terroristen des 11 septembers ja einige
themen raf terroristen machen
september also das world trade center
ist der eben begriff ist ein symbol des
kapitalismus und jeder und jede die in
diesem turm arbeitet selbst ein putzmann
der er auch betroffen waren
selbst wer macht sich schuldig am
kapitalismus und der kapitalismus ist
eine unterdrückung der kapitalismus ist
eine perversion der kapitalismus ist
eine völlig unmoralisch liebens fonds
und ja so eilig wurde argumentiert
vielleicht auch noch verletzt und ich
sage es sicherlich kann man natürlich
den kapitalismus kritisieren ist völlig
legitim aber ich denke eben das kritik
immer konstruktiv sein sollte
ich glaube man darf sehr wohl
kritisiert wird dass sie gar nicht mehr
da ist
es ist der letzte von dem markt
scherbenhaufen zurück ich glaube auch
dass das problem des kommunismus ist
dass er nicht konstruktiv das ist eine
destruktive kritik gemacht kaputt hat
was des tot
beispiel für vorhaben ich finde es hier
nicht die allerbeste verspielen
die sie bringt hier nahm die skating
oder screen komme habe ich schon gelesen
geht es um die rose die da viele
einkaufstüten helden
[Musik]
die eng wie die aussehen wie sie schwer
beladen total woran die bisher total ist
kein tresor
ja wir könnten wir das anders machen
die hätte jetzt neben der md gebe aber
auch sagen kann nicht in den verdacht zu
uns zu kommen
ich glaube ihr nicht dass das typischer
fall verloren ist ein bisschen was schon
die kette erst sagen können
ja genau
genau das sagt könnte st lasst uns doch
mal die maus vor hatten
ob sie hätten manche menschen wollen das
kommt darauf an zu großen respekt aber
auch eine zum beispiel sagt in der
situation selbst wenn man sie fragt bei
dem hinterher sagen können durch die
schweizer auch gesehen
gross hatte da einkaufskörbe und ich hab
jetzt bist du schlechtes gewissen oder
ich bin 20 jahre hätten nämlich
vielleicht solltest du dir vielleicht
die aktion
ja aber ich glaube dass ich denke ich es
war nichts verstanden
wobei nächsten zudem dass die ezb könnte
jetzt sagen warum hast du nicht gut aber
man könnte sich den fall vorstellen wo
der ralf gibt es steht und der
antonstraße zeit und der lbm beamte wie
kommen sie dazu so war es nicht als
könnte man sich vorstellen und dann
werde ich das natürlich gerechtfertigt
aber nicht die einfachste theo dieses
[Musik]
der nach andy denn die wird dann der alv
genossen der kritisiert es gibt in die
form und die form lässt darauf schließen
dass der reihe vielleicht ein bisschen
überzogen die moralische ansprüche hat
aber das ist es nicht
so ist es nicht
und die form der terrorismus in
erscheinung treten form lässt darauf
schließen dass es dem bald heimisch und
was anderes gehen könnte als jetzt im
liegen bloß nehme ich ihm vielleicht
sogar sich selbst oder darum den anderen
religiösen feste form eine partielle
gerechtfertigt
[Musik]
mmh vielleicht
der verhandelte branchen gehalt als auch
man jetzt niemand mehr überzeugt zu
gewinnen ist das dach durch vielleicht
alles zu übernahmen
moralis tisch sagen zu können
jemand der der der dmb hat jetzt ein
schlechtes gewissen hat er fühlt sich
jetzt als unhöflich entzogen
es hat ein bisschen was es geben die
richtung aber zum beispiel sehe ich
jetzt noch nicht direkt wie der der wahl
so stark nach überlebens erheblichkeit
kommt dann nicht der weg
ich finde es andere beispiel besser das
zweite das für mich mir scheint dass man
eben immer noch die selbsttäuschung
überheblich
mit berücksichtigen und die diskret und
drückt sich aus in der form video
realistisch auch wenn man das dann
schwächt ihre freundliche bescheid muss
sein dann reflektiert man eben darauf
passen selbst auch nicht immer wieder
absolute position und terroristen
gegeben
die forschungen des organismus sein weil
hier jetzt nicht mehr
[Musik]
stillschweigend kaufen der demo
realistisch ist weiß ja nicht direkt was
er jetzt sein schaden oder oma beim
unfall zu
er wird sicherlich wissen ein schlechtes
gewissen gut rüber und unterdrückung und
überheblichkeit erfüllt er an die andere
person fühlt sich schlechter
das ist ja dass dieser schaden wird
vielleicht auch beabsichtigt im wallis
muss ich denke durchaus dass jemand der
rest ist
[Musik]
aber die schäden die der terrorismus
einrichtung durch diese noch wie extrem
und ist im see geplanten die sind nicht
nur wird von kritikern der widmung
nachgeholt
wird also ganz dezidiert systematisch an
strafen
die planung auch durchgeführt und zu
nehmen
eine philosophie eingeschrieben das böse
wort terrorismus
die hat etwas sehr treffend dazu auf der
elften september gesagt
das ist eine art von inszenierung
gerecht
diese anschläge auf dem offenen
september waren denn endlich fast schon
kleine spital
ich will das jetzt einen schlussstrich
setzen aber es war schon projekt eine
zelle regierung bestrafen
es war nicht irgendwie jetzt eine
blindwütige redaktion sind es waren also
hochgradig stilistisch inszenieren
extremer sowohl die türme
das ist die mediale präsenz des ist also
hier wird wirklich die strafe zelebriert
ich glaube dass das auch noch zum
terrorismus dazu gehören ich darf man
diese ganzen es videos in diesen
schrecklichen hinrichtungsmethode das
ist alles eine zelebration dass der
straße ich meine dann geht es an den
quälereien förderung
bestrafungsaktionen gerade auch bei den
ranglisten oder
terroristen werden
genauso
im fall die den deswegen so drastisch
ausfällt weiß nicht gerechtfertigt weil
sich der täter
absolut richtig
du bist
oder auch die ganze verfügungsmacht über
das opfer haben wir es ja völlig gerecht
wird beweisen unsere fonds als der täter
ist sich da ganz sicher täuscht sich
natürlich haben interessierte müssten
aber dass es gibt und jeden missbrauch
öffentlich oder auch die religion
geringer und das führt eben
interessanterweise zum aller brutalsten
tötungen die gar nicht mehr im ort
gemacht werden können sie die eine
quälerei oder in der antike blieben beim
elften september
das hatte was von zum spektakel
es hat er auch stadt der welt
richtung mir nicht verstanden es wurde
sogar ästhetische dimension mit
eingeplant
als der terrorismus der versucht seine
aktion der pfosten ästhetisch zu
zelebrieren oder auch das sagt es
jedenfalls dass dann diese form der
strafe fast schon auch als naturgewalt
einzementiert es geht ihr sehr stark
stilisierung auch diese strafe um sich
ganz auf der sicheren seite
genau das ist mit ganz spannende sache
wie hier dann die beschädigung
simplifiziert sich um eltern die glauben
dass für eine zelebration zelebration
der strafe
die betrifft ausgekostet hier wird auch
ganz viele effekte
es hat natürlich auch was von zynismus
ein bisschen das müsste man auch genau
beschreiben ich glaube dass ein
verfahren das ist nicht nur physisches
leid dass es auch nicht um körperliches
leid sind es leid was sich selbst oder
das ist staaten schädigen die sich
selbst als durch und durch
gerechtfertigt steht so muss es das und
das machen beschädigen besonders gefehlt
wenn da gar keine selbstzweifel mehr
auftreten
bei dieser naturgewalt
also man kann über diesen 11 september
das auch eine beschreibung auch von der
sophie gibt es auch einige bücher über
diese ereignisse habe ich glaube
philosophisch kann man dann auch sehr
viel analysieren aus dieser aus diesen
schrecklichen terroranschlägen
haben sie noch andere bemerken
dazu werden unter dem phänomen des
tourismus nach china zu bringen
dr da ist es ihm ganz interessant dass
viele diese terroristinnen dass die aus
dem sehr groß gestand heraus töchter
protestantisches parat
und das sieht man nämlich schon das sind
zu stark
es geht nicht nur mit optionaler aber es
gibt einfach dass sich selbst
radikalisieren
in der gewissheit auf der rechte seite
ich glaube dass das radikalisieren gute
es gibt mich nun der radikalisierung die
im schlechtester der widerklage immer
des gutes tun glauben müssen
derjenige der am ende presse behandelt
immer noch nur hier zu glauben dass er
das gut tut und das scheint
besonders ist ist das eben so grausame
tagen zustande kommen kann weil man eben
so und da nimmt sicher ist dass man auf
der gegenseite ist und dass man es gar
nicht mehr hinterfragen dass der
sozialstaat und das ist grausam den 1
und genau das richtige das schreiben
eigentlich nur ein ausdruck dass sein
letztendlich von der superben einzelne
oder auch gruppen vertreten dass gruppe
neben dann gewisse form von
überheblichkeit exemplifiziert die sich
letztendlich als im radio
qualität und das machen wir alles muss
so gefährlich weil man eigentlich den
richtigen ansatz und findus tätig als
wie können wir das kritisieren
die schlichtung ist das leben des kindes
ist ihr bester qualität
hier ist sozusagen ein paket mit einer
kritik gerade das am anderen ufer
gesichert
du wirst nicht dazu beitragen dass er
ist das nächste mal besser
kritik muss konstruktiv das wäre glaubt
der 1
[Musik]
bei uns weiterhin gelingen würde es doch
sein problem behindert
so bin ich auf der erde sein
deswegen glaube das muss man müssen wir
draußen bis dahin meist wirken sie
können sich ihre eigene meter gemacht
und mein vorschlag werde den vorwurf
dass der hochofen uns nämlich dass das
nur scheinbar und der scheinbar
mobilität und zwar der überheblichkeit
dietmann neben unter dem deckmantel
heimlich oft über sich selbst geben
betrag
ich glaube es so könnte man eine
journalistin wissen am besten kannst dir
geht es gar nicht um mode geht es tust
du
wenn man das eine mobile ist gegeben
hält dann darf man gespannt sein jeder
sieht reagiert wenn es sind die
klassischen moralisten noch gibt aber er
dann so ein bisschen was müsste man
argumentieren dass du hast mich verletzt
ich fühle mich verletzt
es ist doch selber schuld was kann ich
dafür wenn du es irgendeine spricht ist
die einzig das ist die einsicht dass du
falsch lag das was jetzt hier ein
gesehen wie du willst darauf regiert ist
doch beim soll das nicht zunehmen soll
es akzeptieren
akzeptiert was würden sie schlecht zu
kommen dann kann man ja auch noch immer
ist nicht klar was mich jetzt da
gedrängt das geht schon ab er würde ich
sagen beschliessen
nichts gewusst aber im moment der beste
kritisch werden haus werde bis gar nicht
mehr als du bist ganz normale du bist so
ganz starken bekommt und zwar deswegen
weil du willst die anderen du willst nur
um erhebung mit das wäre zumal
inzwischen aber darüber können kann man
selber schreiben das ist ein thema das
immer mehr jetzt auch hinter auch andere
sächsische internationale forschung
thematisiert wird haben sie noch
verkürzen organismus
falls nicht können sie die auch gerne
noch nachhinein unter dieses
youtube-video posten nachdem es sprechen
müssen ich wünsche mir trotz dieser nun
tiefen der menschlichen existenz der
seele noch einen schönen tag in einigen
staaten